[Music]
[Music]
where are we
tokyo
the moving portal makes it harder to
track us seek is the best of them
portals clean we do know shadows
i don't remember this
we don't have to run to phone booths
anymore either
door's only right
set and setting right oh no it's all
about set
and setting
after our first contact went so badly we
thought elements from your past
might help ease you into the present
nothing comforts anxiety like
little nostalgia
we can't see it
but we're all trapped inside these
strange repeating loops
billions of people just living out their
lives
oblivious
but this is the moment for you to show
us what is real
[Music]
i remember this
[Music]
so deja vu
and yet it's obviously all wrong
maybe this isn't the story we think it
is
they taught you good
made you believe their world was all you
deserved
but some part of you knew that was a lie
some part of you remembered what was
real
it's so easy to forget how much noise
the matrix pumps into your head
something else makes the same kind of
noise
war
the most important choice in neil's life
it's my turn to believe in her
[Music]
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you
if you want to see trinity again
i saw this in a dream
my dream ended here
[Music]
i still know kung fu
[Music]
you